so fool what's a fool podcast a manacle
reverb yeah oh yeah that's an echo it's
a reverb hooked up to the keyboards bro
oh yeah oh yeah it might be the mic
right there that's coming through the
yeah yeah well it's still no it's okay
Felipe's mic is not on or there we go
I mean I can just hear Felipe in the
room but not through the mic what's up
that's not you're not controlling the
volume there do you ever know yeah but
you're not me good okay good yeah what's
a full part Kalia was so full podcast
here man we're back we just got back
from Amarillo Texas and McAllen Texas we
got Rodrigo Torres here yeah what's up
hello
down in the weather right now but he's
here like a soldier the soldier but like
always
yeah at least I hear know with purple
and gray here right now that's right
yeah yeah Johnny rocky right here man
with a 2-page Julia we got Julio here
from South sexuality more oldest right
here you ever hear from Instagram he's
our little youtuber viral
I think Eric Bobo from Cypress Hill I
really know yeah yeah he just he just
said something on the video that you put
up today cool what's up everybody
Cheerilee right here upcoming shows
Lubbock Texas August 24th that's this
next week Lorado text says August 25th
Brea California August 30 to September
the second Labor Day weekend at Brea
improv that show is starting
out yes Saturday I think it's already
done we might add another week I don't
know
Atlantic City New Jersey there's plenty
of tickets over there so if you can't
get to prayer man make it up to New
Jersey watching these T September 8th at
National Harbor Casino what that other
way they're done already
also coming up in September Las Vegas
Laughlin
Lexington Kentucky hey y'all would you
go make it out some more whiskey and
this arena will Massachusetts check out
Philly before dark our last tour for our
upcoming shows that ticket info I know
that started when I come in this place
must be something I don't know it is we
got Johnny man right here with no
hickeys he stayed home for a while no
one's gonna get on my man
if you're actually gonna get it can
hickeys in your 40s you might be
enjoying Iraqis family but some broad
[Laughter]
what we love Texas a day early man buy a
brisket bar man what happened but then I
went to the bathroom after a red cedar
oh [ __ ] you know how hard that was they
too though you know how hard it is to
find a dentist at 8:00 in the morning in
LA for Amarillo Texas and it's Thursday
already like almost afternoon there and
then she tells me hey I don't know if
anybody can fit you in today but on
Friday you're not gonna have any luck
cuz all the dentists over here they cut
down on Fridays I was like watch we're
gonna do
I was freaking out luckily we found
somebody but oh my god we get there man
yeah you needed the dental dental hustle
no try again is if your gums hurts I hit
my stomach blood some of you [ __ ]
better save that so they just cleans it
all right take me back up but I'm
worried brokers when I wouldn't when I
took a picture where there was yellow
did the holy white so I said I might be
infected but it'll hurt so maybe okay I
think maybe that's where it was loose
and there was coffee and stuff getting
inside on that little baby the little
anchor tooth you know that's what I'm
thinking well you know because he uses
the water pick it out oh of course dude
but I think he's saying he was
sandblasting his dental cement away
[Laughter]
my doctor for an eyedropper like I'm
sorry go ahead
we got into in the hotel yeah but they
didn't find it she's seen hi she knew
she knew the market value
everybody got walking around nice and
nothing just old cowboy daily no forget
the rail no they said we know bro
because you have the original can no
they said that it's not time to kick in
for the refill yet they have to wait
till that time come so he had to wait
about four weeks right there's a
Costanza character Kate wait how so so
hurry down or wait three weeks
yeah like insurance won't cover it again
until it's time this is my whole life
yeah dude it's a topical fungicide for
his feet and so when we get there bro I
told her mana I think every girl told
you I have keep it that quiet it's me
but it like comes it goes goes up but
they would have wear these shoes because
they're like croc Crocs that gets crying
so my foot my toe deal with hitting the
top so he totally hated it felt like if
fun I still do so I wanted there and
that Russian lady goes I said listen
doctor I we have my socks off bro ready
she lifted me younger than a baby and I
told her what I think is a goat or no
all right here's let's say yes and she
taught you I hold on
that's what pliers bro she dug you there
real quick
haha I might have to dumb dumb I might
have to love it it's just clipped it on
do it went from thank you for a 200%
pain if you touch it to dirty dog
it was a little point y'all hittin it oh
my god dude she didn't have to hold my
toe
she only hold my toe foot at the bottom
and then that [ __ ] plier goes on
their dog and cuts the nail straight so
it will go back grow back straight cuz
everything has to be flush oh you can't
be going into it they will do my toe
after to the shower I saw at their blog
it was like a straight cut like my toe
my deal was I really get it like scared
that's what the pain is this is some
podcast problem look like dubs if your
big toe to look at thumb you have an
ingrown toenail man just go ahead and
pay the money man
she'll cut that [ __ ] what you Andre it
was good dude
and then I've told about that know what
they're very started like do that to
your wife lotta we just finished cause -
[Laughter]
yeah it's originally on TNT right well
gee so do you also do an emergency
haircut man Chaz Chaz from Amarillo
shut up to that weird place for gonna
breakfast burritos oh yeah Johnny Rock
is here alright got excited when I
thought about those burritos though
these are the ones from the that weird
place in EM you know carrots not carrots
with a game carrots not carrots that
doughnuts to him it was good scones
how about Toby I mean I need me a number
one over that guy Beto's with fries at
2:00 in the morning huh
yeah yeah that cook came out I was I
would he gets one and then I came in
type I shout out to the hotel room order
the Hyatt
yeah he'll tear the garden
Embassy Suites everything sweets we were
hanging out outside I think you got it
already
Maddie's gay they begin food which I
want to eat and that full hooked up
cooter Berger no food a burger but it
was a ground beef and brisket so they
got like some raw brisket and they
[ __ ] dog they grounded up with a
regular beef and he made of a hamburger
and the one of the most dirty is like
this his rent his our wings had a lot of
sauce and barbecue look good I ain't
real slower by tooth he had once earlier
the party has turned out to the dope
dealer podcast there my homegirl who you
entered a podcast to or shooting your
show that black girl with threads she
has that joke about out there :
Oh in wonder why eduarda way what's she
been up to bro she the one that has some
little boots no that's a funny lady
though the black a meteorite is the
female comedian with props and she'll
come up with props and it whatever y'all
gonna kick off mask is what mess is
gonna go come on if y'all can go all the
best kids they should bring out these
little tiny Mexican cowboy boots who
gonna wear these she was doing and she
were killed
hell yeah when anthrax was huge because
she was hitting people with the powder -
right before I go don't anybody try to
mail me this powder she don't my cell
you know Alan anthrax is cocaine how
about you bring that I love that tug
again every time a Stanley grab it okay
did at that time we were at the hop and
the bunny lady came out with a full hour
show and she had these two girls dancing
the last other two black girls I don't
remember it but snow joy with Oxnard
Oxnard sign gave up we need greed with
all three 30 people 30 people we shift
we went to dinner for some of them there
oh it's 30 strong move in already at the
top that bro at this vanished comedy for
the first time oh yeah and as he was
that well you know be brought about to
prepare so many of the jokes by minute
before I couldn't know if a stripper
Spanish and her Papa tight mi Patito
I see her buffer de Julio I don't know I
really speak towards vanished I mean I
do when her mother indeed exactly
who do the keyboard is right here late
Liberace Liberace so we're probably old
I was born in Los Angeles we're at and
in a city of Bell small cities Maywood
was Bell with a white people make a
living both artists my parents are from
Mexico Mexico yeah how'd you make it out
to go to high school here and up early
yeah I went to every high school you can
imagine you're bad kid no he's a ditch
your Excuse die just so I got bored in
class and it just took off what all my
other blind friends will take off in
court McDonald's
the groom is bad
marshal John Marshall High yeah I with
the John Marshall and I went to I went
to an orb on Odin Carson and didn't like
you know hanging out too much you know
what the blind folks at that time I felt
a little too normal just I was very
independent I saw him and I finally
settled on about high school those kids
at the black school that is why I never
did any drugs in the time
did Sheila [ __ ] or ditching just going
to eat going to Roosevelt
Garfield extension program in East Los
Angeles it was it gets old school just
for like no no no go ahead but a lot of
hits of Georgia make glad to be free
food I will go to the Hat
in a bun reporting to the Hat yeah yeah
maybe four of our pastrami [ __ ] is up
those chili fries cheese fries yeah have
you ever tried the gravy fries hair
dollar like that is just fries with
gravy and cheese no that's great it's
like poutine but without them yeah we
good whatever you put on it
it's like potatoes and gravy what's
exactly the hack about a report extra
chili extra cheese they never melt that
[ __ ] yeah there's slices yeah do
that Tommy ours was shredded but made it
melted yeah but we could ask yeah but if
the cheese or not it'll melt itself
maybe and that's what they told us but
we didn't get chili on ours we got
cheese remember I know what yeah and
they refused to back bro they're not
gonna give us that day they should you
put the butter cheese on top oh they
have it but I like the cheese slices oh
yeah so I had like a [ __ ] nice broad
chili and cheese slices on the rate
I never had a pastrami - later on it
would have older unity about the
pastrami but there's chili fries you
never ditch and go to jakey's are you
kidding my face yeah bunch of much again
you get it to a Fight Club like one of
us with almost zero did that no oh oh my
oh my blind friends were kind of boring
they're just I don't play somewhere else
I guess
here is rebel what'd ya do for fun WI is
eating we used to like taking trips we
just like taking trips and I guess most
of the you know fun times we had we were
younger you know we would go out and to
the beach and run into girls and be like
oh sorry I'm looking for a spell
my videos a good excuse to get help
yeah we would listen to the girls and
[Laughter]
well we had to guess we're all blind no
I wouldn't do that I'll give them home
even non-flying guys do that I'll do
that what they do I know why guys hug oh
you Joe yeah but I think it's better
when you're blind when you're black
will hug you and squeeze but that fool
bed used to walk around at night with
binoculars and then he'll be creeping up
people taking showers I think our 9
today
peeping peeping does but the litter
don't rope it he just looking at images
weird dude that's too weird
I think we're doing something you watch
[Laughter]
I've known fools that'll be happy just a
glimpse was it throw rocket that vision
was that yeah was your those overalls in
high school
what's a Louisville Jack - magic jammer
over here Doug
we're over your office you want the high
school in the 90s then No mm yeah Bobby
so you graduated high school 2005 Wow
yeah went to college I went to Johnson
and Wales in Rhode Island then I went to
Azusa Pacific in California Johnson &
Wales yeah I was a business manager as a
4.0 student there and I wanted to do
comedy and I moved back to California
didn't graduate
now I graduated I worked I went to
school and did you agree yeah English no
I can't do it because I don't got the
credentials that's like another year of
school how many units it's like 12 or 14
or some [ __ ] like that study your ass -
I deployed with me that's pretty much
what I did
yeah it was a business major and then
went to English
needed comedy Johnny looks like a Shia
LaBeouf on a bad day this one giant
robot bro flying robot ah Japanese sure
you're there so who lose a robot no I
haven't it's about
everybody I mean I have it but it's not
gonna you're not gonna hear it you will
see all right there yeah but you won't
see right there so the audience won't
know you're talking about you want to
play it scratch it
it's striking please tell my sure that
I'll do it I'll do the audio you start
watching that when you're a kid or just
recently know the kid just join a soccer
flight robot these guys were were were
part of the good guys bro and they had
enemies and this little boy he used to
control a robot with his watch you know
a 100 watch that that and you know the
bad guys right here Gero one gyro
balloon King Tut but his arms his arms
and his hands have bullets and missiles
Koshu like the little boy or go try
robot shoot missiles those cars are fake
this was a Japanese show even with all
the Japanese actors in English movies
and then he would happen again so little
desert who's this fool in the green dog
guy and they pull a guy's the captain
and that watch was opposed to go to a
bad guy but Johnny Sacco put it on when
they were testing it out a pleated and
he put it on and when he opened the
watch I spoke to it the robot with
programs with boys forever that's badass
so the bad guys are was gonna kidnap him
and make him a bad kid but they uh they
made a fake one
eyebrows that he's a bad guy yeah he
throw this away and he started a tsunami
all right
but the theme song was all right was so
poop podcast we got that roof that would
like to watch would you go your party
more like God I know [ __ ] London lost
you were like a Voltron guy huh Voltron
was cool ten formers g-force hmm
Power Rangers Power Ranger
get into it but that was a [ __ ] bag yeah
I was eight twelve bro yeah watch your
best you it's like Thundercats there
just disappeared roll you'll never be
still a regular TV 52 yeah and that's
what channel 52 before what's that in
mundo yeah
so that shall be in English and then
I've started some others show or start I
would like that was like are like
[ __ ] now with that show car would
[Music]
Animorphs that's a Gobots polishers oh
yeah animals they know that Paul Reid
you were throwing up over a news I don't
know what you did you stuff yeah what's
up fool so you get the old McAllen Texas
bro how would that fool dinner tell me
what happened afterwards dude we went to
the Centennial do with Alec Rios dude
dinner had a filet mignon chicken-fried
steak little cube of what Kiwi and a
Kiwis water money and cheese and cheese
the Rubik's Cube yeah everyone great on
that just hold that shrimp shrimp huge
don't come fist I had garlic ate it
no I was drizzled with some sauce I
think it was like some type of like
little like watery clam sauce and also
that Rubik's Cube Chanukah had a cashew
sauce oh yeah drizzled on top of it yeah
a little bit of strawberries on the top
and you know some apples and what else
there was a chicken I didn't really know
what the chicken was but it was a bait
like it look like it was like bacon and
fried chicken fries Dean no the other
one the slice is the chicken was so food
that we call him Giancarlo or Christian
singer Julio so when you start being a
dog and became a musician I've always
done music I since I was 10
I'm 35 now my grandfather my grandfather
recipes in my uncle's rest in peace
guarded music yeah they are played in
mariachi stereos my mom was an actor
before I was born
she used to dance Mambo in Africa and
when I was born she had to let it go I
was born with a lot of complications and
uh yeah and I played in a couple bands
when I was you know 16 17 up to a while
20 Wars and I got I got bored and I went
solo ever since you were born you were
born without sight I was born blind yes
yes yes I was born blind but I've never
seen it as an obstacle I think you know
when you were five with your stakes that
one able though tough time for you orgy
is adapted to life right away all right
I think it's it's always been tough even
now - sure
everything changes though yeah I mean
things change and you gotta you know
grow up with you know going to like a
normal school I can cite it you know
like better high school and things like
that or regular schools and you deal
with you know people making fun of you
just a bunch of crap and even now it
just becomes twice as harder you just
don't know what what you're gonna run
into what all the things that are going
on in the world that you were bullied
very little but I was I was fight back
were you funny um I think it disciplined
it it depending on the situation I've
gotten a couple fights it was crazy
once once once I had them in my hands
they weren't going I used to wrestle
blind dudes in wrestling they're good I
went to judo you know I guess they just
got all interesting it depends on the
situation so how did so they didn't
think of it as a disadvantage at all -
you don't need your sight that much in
wrestling or well no cuz I guess the
only thing was you you couldn't like run
away from the gutter like make enough
space so you'd always have to be contact
so you have to always know yeah and
they're like it's it's very movement
based so even if you if you have your
eyes covered you get hit in the face you
still know what you're doing yeah I saw
where the black guy took all the lies in
the bouquet baby to share that because
bright side is the one with the blank
spot it's a movie about uh about that
real good huh
right that's fury always blind fury yeah
my my acting teacher was in that movie
he fights and he was of the TV daddy's
job that way active teaching us at a
magnet school you could teach acting
seriously you have enough credentials to
go do it doesn't mean you'd be good at
it
[Laughter]
seven years so you fought the kids a
brutal dude but I but there's some I've
seen about people with outside you know
move on like a Dodger Stadium I will see
uh this blind man he would go to all the
games and just he'll buy his ticket but
no stabbed by his seed and listen to the
game on the radio they're like he'll get
excited too because everybody get
excited and still go to the restaurant
bro
just walk down I get [ __ ] up too
little stick oh they do get [ __ ] up
too
he'll get father by himself I didn't
like when the game's over he'll leave
but I guess yeah I guess I like a band
that takes him home but goddamn bro
if you were there hanging out talk to
him you think he was blinded you think
that he is involved in the game just
like me hmm
so you a Dodger fan basketball what
Lakers Lakers yes LeBron is here and I'm
okay with it I mean I want to see ya to
face it like seven times if they finally
just come on how'd you learn how to play
Julio did you learn by ear did your
family teach you i I played by ear when
I read music as well Braille I read
Braille music yeah and I also got a lot
of teaching in school I always loved
music it's always been my passion so
I've never watched TV or not like that
even if I wanted to I wasn't into it you
know I heard of other you know things
you guys been talking about but I've
never been you know one to be sitting on
TV just chillin nah my keyboards with me
at all times so it's always been music
my entire life it's like those guys who
really get into playing guitar you know
like any van halen's started late but
when he had it once he had it he never
put his guitar down just always had it
with him you know always played in a
spare every spare moment cute little
keyboard in my car and go to Starbucks a
lot and sit there and just go people
walk up dollars again have you ever done
any busking like street performance oh
yeah yeah I used to do it downtown I
used to make baingan 11 and maple
oh that's a perfect oh oh there by the
bird
[Laughter]
in our industry man the only place we
you can have a list that's odd and
you'll find everything there I need
fabric and beads are the fabric my keys
13:1 tamponade us all wrapped in bacon
on the street being a food prepared by
has got a roulette door restaurant now
in the garment industry if you haven't
one thing about eating is called
typeless
what is that called veggie pizza no Ali
vegan that words are the meaning in
joint do they were spicy spicy soup is
the best it's the best what's the fair
food Julio pizza no he got burned out on
that as a high schooler enchiladas work
when our needle used to be morally
I could live without Molly that's my
long yeah November but have to be
without with us with a little juice no
water
yeah the pepper has a little water in it
it's gonna broth although red like that
like kind of like the south so that goes
on the Caputo's right the watery red
sauce ceviche what pause for a second
your shirt they can have on is
sale now the podcast shirt and the
burgundy one - they are on sale at
Philly pace WorldCom slash shop and
their 25 bucks online and that's it you
can order them today and we have some
tote bags we added one tote bag is $5
and then there's a one that's more
sturdy that's 15 bucks and we have lots
of stuff when you first started yes when
I saw you in that video I thought you
started like a church first I played in
church I did play in church I I did play
a good while in church but then I saw as
I started you know progressing and
learning more they wanted me to stay a
lot more in charge nice and now I can't
do it I needed money back then but if
you were to compare the budget we're
getting a wild coyote compared to the
most alcohol they were making everybody
there's been a hundred barley man like
even asking for two more two more drink
tickets from that fool you act like
you're [ __ ] and asking her for a
kidney dog don't know where we're
thinking about it because that drab that
I was there what are the different type
of wild coyotes and I'm there those
things ever waitresses but I can't I
don't see their faces I just don't know
their faces but they were out there and
they were running the same scam bro at a
different place but where other where
they got rid of a big ticket but they're
actually trader men for money we're
never doing that you know which ones
they just keep looking for me yeah
there's always the scam people would
think oh man scab or something so I
don't know how they do the drink ticket
so I'll give you the oztent drink
tickets everybody gets a drink
you you put your charger probably take
that a month yeah they used average yeah
or they'll use it when they turn in
their cash and their money for the stuff
that they sold they'll turn into drink
tickets meaning this I got five five of
these drinks are not drinks so you turn
that in as part of your cash that counts
five of those drinks on your ticket 20
years ago
oh there was a Miss on shady ass [ __ ]
going down behind your back no they're
not doing that how about their food
apellido you know he used to work over
that the other places used to show with
[ __ ] gonna buy it
pie-ya nobody wanted his pie
you look at a guy that takes ten showers
and still look dirty well isn't that
always harassing the waitresses dude
yeah they grab their butts and chew oh
my god no don't tell me that I'm doing
Christmas parties people corner the both
druggies waitress for the bathroom we
should at this payroll until they give
you a name Daniel but never a smell like
that pretty but yeah Widow yeah yeah
yeah oh my god bro don't have a no extra
Barbe tools though he'll use that to the
bomb to the advantage but you don't wait
shirts man your load HR so we're all
good you had to pick up your kids this
guy have a no line taking me up he's
somewhere bro running a restaurant for
Anthony Bourdain's cuz it were some food
shout out to that mega man or Mario who
shot who did that photo of oriental too
big but the base bro we're Vietnamese
bigger black like stop belly pigs
they're pot-bellied pigs they're not
regular pace bro
yeah exists but everything else with our
point it's just the backdrop the
backdrop bros before the ruler key to
the matrix looks like he's Hamburglar
what's up fool so who lived with us
I am so bad you were like a ladies man
growing up after a plane you had
groupies hey so lo que quiera you didn't
have to pretend to bump into them
they're holding you know the keys for me
[Laughter]
like your fingers
you let go
do you play like song that you re heard
or you make up your own songs I do a lot
of covers I have a couple songs out you
do s da da and I play that Jam
what would you feel bad bro a couple of
beers oh no I've always liked English
music and now I listen to Spanish little
rapper another what's your favorite
music in English music Stevie Wonder
oh yeah yeah Motown stuff like toys -
man you see - I just think or does any
guy we caught up with the cold but I'm
still here yeah brother sisters I do
have two brothers and four sisters music
oh you're the only one keeping the
family to go or talent I think I'm the
only one of those music in my family now
just in my family I'm the one does
comedy for a living everybody for free
you think your sister could beat you and
I'm like a bagging content like she
probably wouldn't go there with you
[Laughter]
that'll be the best they'll be the best
show rows battle with your family
all your kids but there are here you
lost three right get abuja butcher you
know yeah kids can go to school somebody
does request to Julio Plano I not I mean
I know I don't know it do you want to
have them play a couple songs yeah
you ready Julio you do like gigs and
stuff right like I do gigs yeah what can
I finally give their number or however
you want them to contact you yeah or
where you will be next if it's open to
the public
I will be at International House of
Music in downtown LA 339 South Broadway
on Sunday from 12 to 4 that's a play but
they have a little RC dog outside yeah
the dog okay yeah yeah man that for 50
years is running further plays hi Ross
cutlery yeah you got my knives
ya know that please well that place been
a rough trail right Julio yeah
so the world little boys are like if
your father wants to bring one she'll be
a mariachi and you don't know like he
live in a South Central LA you know
there were lines I think you're on a
cheap a cheap accordion a cheap corn
Etta a cheap violin a [ __ ] horn
you get it right there and the guy gives
you credit yeah and if you don't [ __ ]
show up
Costa my dad's like that's cool that's
cool
that is cool they went there I can see
the Internet
International House of music also south
DJ equipment man and they sound like and
then after a while man I remember one
time they were like they sold out on
karaoke machines dude
they were hot everybody was doing it
me and my drink
he said by the way the dimension is
earlier but you look amazing that sure
thank you no it's orange I have a blue
one - it's the Everman this collection
I've never met any of you whatever she
said that I was drawing about bully
because a very attractive what that it
be on all those girls like to act like
they're nerd no they're gamers they're
introverts they're like whatever that's
funny man because I'm back to echo but
up you know remember Lana I want to
mention names but finally I'm following
my people right and it's all like they
used to be like vegan food being rude
then we came lace and vegan food and
that's not following then I saw him I
think oh no it's a private page yeah
like they switch the bait and switch
sort of thing know that I went now other
stuff there's a one little pages you
could go pay was he calling on Instagram
yeah but they sending you to another
page oh if you want to see war yeah like
I guess patron yeah like an ad probably
they probably have an ads well an ad was
so much it wasn't go see the rage
because that they have nasty Poros
barrio girls that bar on Instagram yeah
yeah they say to somewhere else I
haven't seen nasty photo stuff yet I'm
seeing like people yelling never link
I've seen people selling something
you've clicked on
one two three more things and you gonna
pay for that [ __ ] I know I know Tina no
we get it for free on put a porno I'll
play for maybe you think a snapchat we
have a private chat on this story I
never look at stories yeah I think it's
the stories and they have you see more
who is it was it a certain page or a lot
of support for the roaches like I'm just
here and then you're just there yeah I'm
here for you I'm here who you are what's
up morado
Maroni's are you ready
[Music]
English or Spanish hey I wouldn't let
you tell me what you want like what you
were playing at the party started and
when you were like like you were at a
house party and invited you and you're
just about to start we got Julio bored
all this you saw him
so take la meheeco private snaps I said
sister they're closed private snaps no
they can go to youtube.com slash CCC and
it'll be up even after it's live go to
youtube.com slash ATC and watch this
live now or wait till after it's done
and it'll still be there
[Music]
damn how long did it take you to program
everything or get everything set to the
tone that you like and all that stuff I
[Music]
mean did you like preset some of these
sounds and although because it seems
like it's a custom sound almost all
right
[Music]
yeah
in the office I'm the only laughs out
here though yeah what's so cool awesome
yeah cuz you usually have like a rack
above you right like that
mm-hmm how did you learn now that I
memorize word up what a touch you know
that sounds did you practice in plane so
they don't they yeah yeah
it's kind like when you're playing
guitar and you know where your fingers
are gonna jump for the next chord being
ready
[Music]
it sounds real the accordion sounds real
everything sounds very the eruption van
Halen
[Music]
he's even got this slap that me acoustic
players have when they need their own
percussion
[Music]
can you do a peel Camilla you know that
one Emma can you turn up his mic on that
mic good to be up control over that
[Music]
Julio can you turn your mic up a little
bit we have control over that that's
right go ahead
[Music]
No
there we do party what kind of style do
you mostly play what was your favorite
song to play didn't entity s play that
one but generally suppose out
[Music]
some Stevie Wonder oh you're the apple
of my life no I superstitious boogie on
reggae you play Oh Betty what's your
favorite song to play like that really
showcases what you like if you wanted to
impress somebody what would you choose
to play great do you play guitar too and
realize I mean real life I mean a real
guitar no do you know cowboy Szabo
the Hungarian Spanish no that's good
music
Oh Joe California what kill you
[Music]
little dark oh yeah you play alone yeah
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
maura curious what am i are scary heard
the lady from Ipanema
oh yeah you got a little get some silver
[Music]
[Laughter]
so did the ending the business
relationship and your personal
relationship to at the same who said the
thing about we're gonna Sun you guys
sang together all the stuff that you
mentioned you feel I got tenure
[Music]
there's no cordial emeriti acquaintance
which presumably no Gordon
[Music]
perfect you're hired
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah amazing Wow
Cordia let's end on this and then he can
come to this mic after he's done plan
and tell where people can find him oh
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
done that all right awesome
amazing huh so just like that it's crazy
but just just to learn how to put the
the button right the time is hard it's
hard if you see it yeah yeah it's hard
you see go back so tell everybody where
you can we gonna wrap up we can find you
where they can book you um you guys can
book me by calling three two three eight
four two zero two six four don't bug him
with [ __ ] my phone goes on do not
disturb from 5:00 p.m. to 3:00 two three
eight four two zero two six four and I
can play everywhere in Japan China
Mexico wherever you get one I'm ready to
travel you can also look me up on
YouTube and Facebook there Julio
modernist which is ju l io first name
last name is mor Oh n es thank you for
being here I wanna give a shout out to
to gen gaming who's watching from
Scotland by the way gaming to change a
new gen gaming to gen gaming ever like
carrots that we're play for hooking up
that good food I was caught up to that
guy for the sports bro was there even
Toby Rodrigo man he was cool with Johnny
man uh take care of that thank you so
much for listening and we do everything
for the community war so food on exactly
how I saw it and don't forget about
those jokes on yeah and also August 21st
I'll be at the door at the dam with the
Adam hunter I'll be doing spot there and
you know
Rodrigo told me tonight I'm at the haha
few guys at the heart comical you know
and you know got the time with Nick and
Johnny podcast still on what stuff would
that you that I'm about to present that
a rule for leverage or show monoxide no
lady drove himself a minute is
girlfriend over there thank you
[Music]